[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
حوادث القتل في الولايات المتحده تتصاعد
1400 دقيقه خلال العام الجاري
السعوديه تسجل الخطاب في وفيات واصابات
الحوادث المروريه وجدل حول ارتفاع اسعار
التامين
في رابعه
رابعه تتجول في حي حراء الثقافي توفيق
لتاريخ مكه الدين والانسان
والمكانه التاريخيه
وتراقبون لنهائي السوبر السعودي الاتحاد
والفيحاء في صراع اللقب الاول
قالت صحيفه سيارات التي استهدفت مواقع في
اسبانيا
انطلقت من داخل ايران
وسائل الاعلام تابعه للحرس الثوري
الايرانيه اسرائيل بالوقوف خلفه هجومي
للمخابرات الايرانيه انا الموساد هو من
يقف وراء هذا الهجوم وذلك لضلوعه باوقات
سابقه بهاجمات مماثله منها هجمات
المنشاتنا تنزانيا
وكان الحرس الثوري الايرانيه كذا وقوع
هجوم بالطائرات المسيره على موقع عسكريين
في اسوان وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه قالت ان
الدفاعات الجويه تتصدت لهجوم المسيرات
ليله البارحه وكان ناشطون ايرانيون اكدوا
سماع دوي انفجره عند استهدفت مصنعا
للذخيره في اصفهان كما تناقلت مواقع
ايرانيه نبا انفجارات اخرى استهدفت مواقع
فيها مدام كرج وقاعده نوجا ورشت وبالتوازي
تحدثت مصادر اعلاميه الاسرائيليه عن عمليه
في الداخل الايراني وربطت بين توقيتها
وزياره رئيس الاستخبارات الامريكيه
المركزي
مناقشه هذا الملف ينضم الينا من دبي
الصخره المختص في شان الايراني مسعود الفك
ومن القاهره الباحث في وحده الدراسات
الامنيه والعسكريه في مركز الاهرام
للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه احمد
عليبه
اهلا بكم من القاهره سيد احمد اذا صحت هذه
الانباء بان اسرائيل هي التي تقف وراء هذا
الهجوم وانه هناك مشاركه امريكيه ايضا حسب
بعض الوسائل في هذه الضرب هل يعني اننا
امام تحول نوعي في طبيعه مواجهه النظام
الايراني والبرنامج الايراني تحديدا
بمغادره اسرائيل من استراتيجيات حرب الظل
التي كانت تنتهجها الى استراتيجيه الضربات
العسكريه المباشره الان المشاهد داخل
العمليه الايراني
بالتاكيد استاذ خالد هذه الفرضيه اصبحت
قائمه نحن لسنا فقط امام تحول طبيعي نحن
امام نقطه فرقه لحظه لحظه تحول كامله في
ما يتعلق بهذا المشهد الخاص بالملف
الايراني بالتاكيد لا تزال يعني هناك نوع
من الضبابيه حول هذه التفاصيل المساله لا
تتعلق فقط بطبيعه الخريطه التي لم نعرفها
بعد هل فقط اصفهان امام اماكن اخرى من
المؤكد انه كان هناك ضربات على مواقع اخرى
اما ما يتعلق به الجانب الاسرائيلي
بالتاكيد كانت هناك مؤشرات مختلفه في اطار
همم المناوره التي قامت بها اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه الاسبوع على
مدار الاسبوع الماضي والتي حاكت يعني
عمليات
لهجوم مشترك على همم منشاتناويه ايرانيه
عملت ايضا محاكاه على استعدادات له هجوم
بحري شامل من الجانب الايراني جونيور اوكي
20 23 انا اعتقد انها رسمت جزء من هذا
السيناريو الذي نشهده الان كانت هناك ايضا
طائرات استراتيجيه موجوده طائرات درونز
الاركيو انا اعتقد ان هذه الطياره تحديدا
ان هي التي لعبت هذا الدور في داخل ايران
لكن ايضا لدينا مؤشر مهم على انه هذه
الطائرات لم يتم اعتراضها انا اعتقد ان
هذا يعني اختبار كبير له الدفاعات
الايرانيه للوصول الى هذه المواقع على
خريطه واسع في ايران كيف تمكنت من عبور
الساحل الغربي لايران كانت ايران تتبعها
الحرس الثوره يتباهى بان لديه منظومه
دفاعيه متعدده الطبقات في مقر الخاتم
المرسلين في غيره من المناطق من الشمال
الغربي وصوره الى الجنوب حتى قاعده جاسكو
وغيرها وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه يعني ايران
الان في موقف شديد الصعوبه كيف سترد هل
ستكون هناك ضربه ثانيه انا اعتقد انه يعني
هناك قصد من ان يكون الطرف الذي دفع بهذه
العمليه هو يريد ايضا ان يضع ايران في
حسابات
يعني معقده فيما يتعلق بطبيعه هذه النقطه
وعود اليك فيها جيد مسعود همم لماذا
اصبحان تحديد يعني ما هي طبيعه المنشات
المتواجده في هذه المنطقه التي استهدفت
هذه المسيرات وهل يمكن بالفعل ان تنطلق
هذه الطائرات المسيره من الداخل الايراني
اذا اخذنا في الاعتبار ان المناطق
الحدوديه مثلا بعض وسائل الاعلام تحدثت عن
ان الطائرات يمكن ان تكون مطلقه من
اذربيجان مسافه بين الحدود الادربيجانيه
ومنطقه اسبانيا هي اكثر من 1,100 كيلو
تقريبا وكذلك ربما في المناطق الحدوديه اا
الاخرى في همم الغربيه يعني ما هي
احتمالات ان تكون
منطلق هذه الطائرات بالفعل من داخل
الاراضي الايراني
تحياتي لك وادي ضيفك الكريم والمشاهدين
الكرام
حول هذه العمليه ولكن
اكثر النظريات قوه الان في الوقت الحاضر
في الاوسط
الايرانيه تركز على ان العمليات ربما
انطلقت من داخل ايران لان المسيرات كانت
مسيرات صغيره لدى همم حجم المسيرات يتطلب
ان تنطلق من داخل ايران ولكن بالنسبه
لاسباب هذا الهجوم
واصفهان ونعود تالي الى مساله اذربيجان
ودور اذربيجان همم
مصدر مطلع يعتقد بان هذه العمليه جاءت ردا
على عمليات قامت بها ايران على اراضي
كردستان همم ليله الجمعه وفي تلك تم
استهداف همم مركز امريكي حساس على اراضي
اقليم كردستان وما يجعلنا ان نقف عند هذه
النقطه هي تصريحات همم ميرندي همم مستشار
الوفد المفاوض النووي الايراني عندما قال
الاسبوع المقبل سيكون اسبوع ساخن لاسرائيل
ولا اقليم كردستان لماذا اقليم كردستان
يطرحه في الوقت الحاضر ويتكلم عن الانتقام
والرد اعتقد دخلنا في دائره مفرغه من الرد
والرد المضاد في هذه الحاله قد مشهد قد
مشهد عمليات على اراضي كردستان عمان
بالنسبه
لانها لاول مره عندما تم سرقه المنشا
وثائق النوويه الايرانيه من همم
ترقص مع بعض وهي ترقص اباد قريبه
متوتره بين البلدين وخصوصا بعد الهجوم
الاخير قبل يومين على السفاره
الاذربيجانيه في ايران
فقط اريد يعني ان تعطيني فكره عن طبيعه
المنشات الموجوده في اصفهان تحديدا هذه هي
مشاهد للصواريخ البالستيه امم منشات كذلك
تابعه لمراكز ابحاث وبرامج نوويه ايراني
سريع
بالنسبه للمنشات في ايران لا يمكن ان تعرف
ما هي الاسم والعنوان قد يكون وراء الاسم
والعنوان شيئا اخر تركز بعد مثلا كانت
منشئه لانتاج لاجهزه الطرد المركزي ولكن
كان همم تحت اسم مركز غسيل السجاد لذا
الاسم قد يكون في اصفهان ايضا ل- اا صنع
الذخيره ولكن خلف الاخيره قد يكون هناك
نشاط مختلف وهذا امر وارد في داخل ايران
ولكن بالنسبه لمن لديه عناصر على الارض
واا عناصر ميدانيه تنقل له الاخبار لا
يمكن ان يتم بغشه بهذه الاسماء احمد
والمتغيرات التي جعلت اسرائيل اليوم همم
تغادر المنطقه منطقه حرب الظل وتتجه الى
ضرب المباشر
ضرب راس الافعى كمان يقول البعض الان
سؤال مهم يعني وجهه النظر في داخل اسرائيل
انه يعني هناك
صعوبه في ان يتم حسم الملف النووي
الايراني بالطرق التي تم اتباع من قبل
سواء الطرق الدبلوماسيه الخاصه بالاتفاق
النووي او طرق الخاصه بحرب الظل مثل
السايبر وغيرها وانه كل ما فعلته هذه
الخياراته انها عطلت او اجلت فقط همم يعني
قدره ايران على الوصول الى العتبه النوويه
وانها في الاخير همم باتت امام مجرد اتخاذ
قرار يمكن تصنيع قنبله انه وكان يعني
افيدكم خافي تحدث في هذا الامر تفصيلا قبل
ايام او قبل ان يغادر منصبه وقال ان
ايراني يمكننا ان تصنعها اربع قنابل نوويه
اذا ما فكرت في هذا الامر وبالتالي هذا
المتغير في داخل اسرائيل يعود الى انه
الجيش نفسه هو الذي يغير موقفه كان الجيش
قد عرض توجيه هذه ضربه في 2012 من غير ده
كان قال هذا الامر شكل واضح انه نتنياهو
هوبا رايكو وزير الدفاع السابق كان
يوريدان توجيه ضربه لايران في 2012 ولكن
الان انا اتصور انه وفقا لرؤيه او تقديرات
يعني اسرائيليه من الداخل ترى انه هناك
حاجه الى اختبار بديل جديد قد يكون الخيار
العسكري وفي هذا السياق يعني تم الترويج
للمناره جونير اه على انها تاتي في هذا
الصيغه ان الخيار العسكري اصبح واردا
الرئيس ترامب ايضا نقل عن اضاء الرئيس
عفوا بيض النقل عن ادارات ايضا انه لا
يستثني هذا الخيار بشكل او باخر وايضا انا
اتصور انه ايران حتى لو كانت العمليه من
يعني اجريت من الداخل كحدث سيناريوهات
التي يعني يمكن طرحها الان انا اتصور انها
تريد ان يكون يعني انت تتعامل مع قسمه في
الخارج يعني هذا سيكون يعني افضل للجانب
الايراني ربما او وفقا للتفكير الايراني
لديها خصوم كثيرون في المنطقه وبالتالي هي
تبحث عن يعني [__] خصم للرد على هذا الامر
حتى لا يعني تواجه ده يعني هاخذ كذلك وجهه
النظر بشكل سريع هل سترد طهران على هذه
العمليه قبل اذهب قبل ان اذهب الى السيد
مسعود
وباي شكل
انا اعتقد انه يعني سوف تكون هناك يعني
ربما اشكاله همم ربما تستخدم ذلك عن طريق
الوكلاء الموجودين في الساحه السوريه
لتوجيه ضربه لايران سواء مليشياتها او همم
عن طريق حزب الله باستخدام الدرونز او
ربما صواريخ ايضا ممكن يشرح روسيه ان تشكل
تهديد على قطع بحريه امريكيه موجوده في
المنطقه او ربما ايران نفسها من خلال هجوم
بشكل او باخر لاستهداف همم يعني همم اصول
عسكريه امريكيه موجوده في المنطقه وكانت
يعني مناره الاخيره فيها اشارات لمحاكاه
ايضا لامر بهذا الشكل ما رايك سيد مسعود
يعني اذا كان اذا صدق سيناري وان تكون هذه
الضربه من الداخل الايراني يعني نحن امام
مرحله متقدمه في مساله الاختراق همم
للمساد همم لكذلك شبكه اخرى في داخل
الاراضي همم بشكل عميق جدا
وكذلك هناك ازمه يعانيها النظام الايراني
كذلك بشكل اعمق في داخل تركيبه هذا النظام
في هذه المظاهرات والاحتجاجات التي تنتشر
انتشار النار في الهاشم في كل الاراضي
الايرانيه هل يمكن للنظام الايراني اليوم
ان يتخذ هكذا قرار ويخاطر برد عسكري
بيستهدف فيه اسرائيل في العمق الاسرائيلي
وفي مناطق اخرى في هذا التوقيت بالنسبه
لنظام
سؤال مهم جدا مهم للغايه هل ايران بوضعها
الاقتصادي هل النظام الذي شرعيته تحت
طائله ضربات المحتاجين
هل في هذه الظروف الذي هو قد يواجه ثوره
الجياع في الداخل نتيجه للتضخم نتيجه
للغلاف
واستمرار العقوبات هل يتجرا النظام ان يشن
هجوم على اسرائيل او على مصالح الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وقواعدها كاجراء
انتقامي اعتقد لو كان النظام الايراني
الا انه لو فضل عقليه التخور قد يقوم
بمغامره الخارج
قبل قليل تابعنا مؤتمر صحفيا ربما ياتي في
اطار وقف حاله التصعيد
بان وزير الخارجيه القطري يحمل رساله من
الاطراف التي تريد تفاوض حول ملف النووي
وقد تكون الرساله اوسع من الملف النووي
ويشمل قضايا اخرى خاصه القضيه الحاليه
التي اعتبرها قضيه ساخنه قد تفجر الوضع
بين ايران وتوصل لها الى نقطه العوده شكرا
جزيلا لكم ما من دبي مسعود الفكه المختص
في شان الايراني من القاهره الباحث في
وحده دراسات الامنيه والعسكريه في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
احمد شكرا جزيلا
رابعه بعد قليل
وزير الاقتصاد الفرنسيه يؤكدوا للعربيه
لدينا علاقات ثنائيه مبنيه على الثقه مع
السعوديه
في واشنطن
رعاياها من الاقتراب من مناطق الاحتجاجات
وتباعي ما تصدره الجهات المختصه من
تعليمات السلام السلامه
يوم امس السبت حيث اشعل متظاهرنا النار في
سياره الشرطه وحطم ونوافذ مباني
[موسيقى]
ونبقى ايضا في امريكا التي تشهد المزيد من
اعمال العنف المسلح راح ضحيتها المئات
خلال اول 29 يوما فقط من العام الجاريه
2023 زميل سالم راجح يعطينا بعضا من ارقام
العنف الذي تعيشه او عاشته عده ولايات
امريكيه في الايام الاخيره
هل امريكا امنه السؤال الابرز هذه الايام
بعد مقتل المبتعث السعودي الوليد الغريبي
على يد مواطنه امريكيه في ولايه بنسلفانيا
هذا السؤال قادنا الى البحث عن جرائم
العنف بالاسلحه كل الولايات المتحده في
اول 25 يوما من العام الجاري 20 23 سجلت
99 حاله اطلاق نار في عموم الولايات وفقا
لموقعي ارشيف العنف المسلح الذي كشف ايضا
عن تسجيل
1400 وفاه بالاسلحه منذ مطلع العام الجاري
واكثر من 2400 اصابه اضافه الى
1850 حاله انتحار عدد كبير من الاطفال
ذهبوا ضحيه هذا العنف في الاسابيع الاربعه
الاولى من العام الجاري 20-23 وفقا للموقع
حيث يلقيها 55
دون ال 11
مصرعهم نتيجه استخدام الاسلحه في اعمال
عنف في 18 ولايه امريكيه فضلا عن المصابين
هذه الارقام مشاهدينا مرشحه للزياده خلال
عرضي هذه الفقره
الامريكي احمد الحمدي سيد احمد اهلا وسهلا
بك معي في نشرته
ارقام كبيره 39 حاله اطلاق نار 1400 في
اول شهر من السنه فقط في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
ما الذي يحدث في امريكا هلا امريكا
يعني بغرض تحقيق منافعه يعني تجاره
ممنوعات او سطو بانواعه هذا النوع من
الاجرام
ليس منتشرا في امريكا اكثر من الدول
المثيله يعني من المعدلات متقاربه في
الدول المتماثله بامريكا ليست حالا خاصه
ولكن لدينا نوع اخر من العنف يعني لا ادري
كيف يمكن تسميته ربما اللي ينتج عن
الانفجار العواطف سواء كانت بغرض الانتقام
او بغرض المشكله نفسيه معينه او مشكله
عمليه احيانا يعني ضد زملاء العمل تحدث
هؤلاء الافراد عاده غير معتدين للاجرام
ولكنه يتعرضون لظروف معينه يعني تؤدي الى
حاله الانفجار هذه المشكله التي تواجه
امريكا لانه هذه الفئه تستطيع الوصول
للسلاح في امريكا بسهوله كبيره جدا مقارنه
بغالبيه الدول العالم وهذه يعني الحوادث
اللي معدلاتها عاليه في امريكا وتمثل
مشكله حقيقيه يعني تجعل امريكا يمكن ان
تصنف بانها غير امنها مقارنه بالدول
المماثله ان نتحدث عن ولا معينه ام ان
الامر يشمل كل الولايات الموجوده في في
الولايات المتحده اليوم
بالنسبه للنوع الاول الاجرام من معتدي
الاج
راء ما تم محصور في مناطق يعني هو في جميع
الولايات ولكنه في مناطق معينه داخل المدن
يعني هناك احياء معينه معروفه انها يعني
العصابات تمارس فيها نشاط عالي سواء في
تجاره المخدرات او اي تجارات اي شيء ممنوع
وعاده تكون في الجرائم مع ثلاثه جرائم
فيها مرتفعه وغالبيه هذه الجرائم تكون بين
المجرمين وبينهم البعض سواء صراعات على
النفوذ وشابه ولكنه بالنسبه للنوع الثاني
من الجرائم اللي هو يعني
جرائم العاطفيه هذه لا هذه موسوعه في كل
مكان وتحدث في كل مكان لا يوجد استثناء
يعني حتى الاماكن
همم في كل مدينه اما اما سبق حدثت فيها
حادثه في نفس المدينه او في منطقه قريبه
جدا منها
بالتالي اليوم كيف تتعامل الاداره
الامريكيه هل هناك بشعور بحاله من القلق
تستوجب تحرك يعني اقوى في التعامل مع كاد
التصاعد في ارقام حالات العنف والعنف
المجتمعي الموجود الان في الولايات
المتحده
في هذا المجال لانه نقطه صراع سياسي بين
تيارات مختلفه يعني هناك التيار مدعوم من
همم يعني من اللوبي مصنعيش سلاح يمنع
التحرك اضافه الى وجود تاييد شعبي يعني
ثقافه امتلاك السلاح لاسباب مختلفه ثقافه
متاصل لدى الشعب الامريكي لذلك هناك في لا
باس بها من المواطنين يرون ان حريه الوصول
للسلاح اساسي للمواطن لا يجب المساس به
لذلك هناك مقاومه عاليه للتحركات في هذا
الاتجاه لذلك يعني راينا انه لمده 30 سنه
لم يصدر اي قانون يقيد باي درجه من
التقييد العمليه التداول الاسلحه وحملها
باستثناء قانون يعتبر يعني خطوه صغيره جدا
في هذا الاتجاه الصدر العام الماضي طيب
سيد احمد انت من خلال مركبتك اليوم نتحدث
عن تصاعد في جرائم معينه مقارنه تتحدث عن
التطرف مثلا عن كراهيه عن اج مع استهداف
للاجانب هل هناك تميز بين الارقام
والسؤال الاخير اذا كيف نجحت مثل هذه
الحوادث الان اذا وصفناها بحوادث ارهاب
محليه كما يرى البعض يعني كيف يعني نجحت
في بسط سيطرتها ربما وهيمنتها بهذا الشكل
في في في كثير من المناطق الولايات في
امريكا
اكبر من هذه الحوادث حوادث عشوائيه طبعا
هناك حوادث كراهيه هناك حوادث انتقامه
هناك حوادث ناتجه يعني عن العنصريه سواء
كانت ضد الاقليات ضد المهاجرين او حتى ضد
بعض الفئات الدينيه ولكن هذه الحوادث لا
تمثل نسبه كبيره النسبه الاكبر يعني
عشوائيه بدرجه كبيره رايناها تحدث كثيرا
داخل المدارس مثلا في المدارس لا يوجد
استهداف لفعل معينه احد الطلبه فقط للجميع
همم براينا الحدث الاخير الحدث في سان
فرانسيسكو همم كان يعني ال- ال- القاتل
والمقتولين كلهم عمال زراعه من اصول صينيه
كانت يعني مشكله همم مشكله حاله عمل يعني
مشكله بين العامل وبين ان الاداره
والزملاء فبالتالي النسبه الكبرى هي فيها
معدل عشوائيه عالي وهذا ما يخيف الناس
لانك لا تعرف متى سيحدث يعني شخص ما قريب
منك سواء قريب من مكان سكنك او مكان عملك
او مكان دراستك سينفجر ويبدا بقتل الجميع
هل هناك يعني حوامل محدده هل يمكن للقول
مثلا بانه همم هناك دور كبير لوسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي اليوم في نشر حاله من
من العنف والعنف المضاد حال من الكراهيه
للطرف الاخر داخل المجتمع الامريكي
بالنسبه يعني
للتواصل الاجتماعي وما شابه هي رفعت مستوى
العنف يعني العنف
العنصر سواء كان موجه ضد في يعني فئه
دينيه او عراقيه او حتى ضد يعني المعارضه
السياسي في السياسيه ولكنها كما ذكرنا هذه
ليست النسبه الاكبر النسبه الاكبر هي
العشوائيه والعشوائيه ترتفع بسبب يعني شبه
حصري اللي هو السلاح اولا والصحه النفسيه
ثانيه يعني هناك ضعف في مستوى تقديم الصحه
النفسيه للفئات الاقل يعني الاقل قدره
ماديه اضافه الى سهوله الوصول للسلاح يعني
في مناطق عديده في غالبيه امريكا يمكن
الوصول لاسلحه قتاليه يعني اسلحه مخصصه
للجيوش بسهوله كبيره يعني باي واحد يقدر
يروح لاي محل يشتري البندقيه يعني طبعا
ليست اليه ولكن بندقيه حربيه مخصصه
خلال ساعات واحيانا في بعض الاماكن عندما
يكون متشددين خلال الايام
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه هذا من هيوستن همم
الباخت في الشان الامريكي احمد الحمدي
في مقابله مع العربيه هكذا وزير الاقتصاد
والماليه الفرنسي برونو لومير ان العلاقات
الاقتصاديه بين السعوديه وفرنس متينه جدا
مشيرا الى ان تواجده في الرياض يتيل البحث
عن تعزيز للعلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين
في كافه القطاعات التي يمكن تعزيزها
اولا كما قلتي لدينا علاقات اقتصاديه قويه
بين فرنسا والسعوديه ليس هذا فحسن لدينا
ايضا على خاص ثنائيه مبنيه على الثقه لقد
زار صاحب السمو فرع السا خلال الاشهر
الماضيه وقد قرر صاحب السمو الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون تعزيز العلاقات
الثنائيه بين السعوديه وفرنسا ان اليوم
هنا في الرياض لبحث كل القطاعات التي
اعتقد انه يمكنني تعزيز التعاون فيها
والاقتصاد الفرنسيه ذكر العربيه ايضا بان
القطاع يشكل التحديات عده وهو الامر الذي
يستوجب تعزيز التعاون سعوديات في ملفات
تتعلق منها الطاقه المتجدده والهيدروجين
وغيرها
على سبيل المثال جميعنا نعلم اننا نواجه
بعض التحديات بخصوص التغير المناخ ومن
الضروري تعزيز التعاون مع السعوديه في ما
يخص الطاقه المتجدده والهيدروجين هناك
ايضا تعاون مشترك في قطاعات اخرى غطاء
المواصلات وغيرها من القطاعات انا اتمنى
ان تكون الزيارات الثنائيه بين صاحب السمو
والرئيس مكروه بدايه علاقته اقتصاديه اقوى
في المستقبل بين البلدين همم
ادرى تقرير لجنه الوزاريه للسلامه
المروريه في السعوديه عن انخفاض اعداد
الحوادث الجسيمه في العام 2022 بنسبه
تقترب من السبعه في المئه مقارنه بالعام
2021 في الوقت الذي ارتفعت فيه حوادث
السلفيات بنسبه 28
جدل حول ارتفاع يسار التامين
السلامه المروريه خلال العام الماضي في
السعوديه تقرير اصدرته اللجنه الوزاريه
السلامه المروريه اخيرا اظهرا نتائج ملف
السلامه المروريه اتقل بين انخفاض اعداد
المتوفين نتيجه الحوادث حيث بلغت اربعه
الاف
و55 متوفى بنسبه انخفاض بلغت اثنين فاصله
واحد في المئه مقارنه بالعام 2020 اعداد
المصابين نتيجه الحوادث هي الاخرى انخفضت
حيث بلغت في العام الماضي اكثر من 24,000
مسجله انخفاضا بنسبه اثنين فاصله سبعه في
المئه عن العامل الذي سبقه الحوادث
الجسيمه ايضا سجلت انخفاضا بنسبه 6.8%
مقارنه بالعام 2021 حيث بلغت في العام
الماضي
16000 و900 حادثه ج اما الارتفاع الوحيد
فكان من نصيب حوادث التلفيات حيث بلغت في
العام الماضي اكثر من مليون و800.000
بارتفاعا يقدر ب 28% عن العام 2021
ورغم ان الارقام تعكس فعاليه الانظمه
والتزام السائقين للتقليل من الحوادث
المروريه وما يتبعها الا ان الارتفاع
الكبير الذي حل بارقام حوادث السلفيات قد
يكون من اهم الاسباب التي دفعت اسعار
التامين على المركبات الارتفاع غير معهود
في السوق السعوديه اذ اقتربت نسبه
الارتفاع الى الضعف تقريبا وسط استياء
عاما بين ملاك المركبات خصوصا من يؤكد ان
سجل له خادم من الحوادث لكنها ميزه لم
تحميه من غلاء الاسعار الذي طال الجميع
في رابعه بعد قليل
بعد ثلاثه عوامل من التوقف صحيفه الحياه
تعود للنشر بحله رقميه البدايه مطلع العام
المقبل
حوادث القتل في الولايات المتحده تتصاعد
1400 ضحيه خلال العام الجاري 2023
السعوديه تسجل انخفاضا في وفيات واصابات
الحوادث المروريه وجدل حول ارتفاع اسعار
التامين
ورابعه تتجول في حي حراء الثقافي توثيق
لتاريخ مكه الدين والانسان والمكانه
التاريخيه
الترقبوا لنهائي السوبر السعودي الاتحاد
والفيحاء في صراع السوبر الاول
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد اغلاقها قبل ان نحوي
ثلاثه اعوام تعود صحيفه الحياه الى الحياه
مجددا بعد عزمها اعاده جدوله ديونها
بالاتفاق مع الدائن الحياه اكدت في بيان
صادر على حسابها في فيسبوك انا عودتها
المقرره بدايه العام
2024 ستتحولوا الى شبكه تواصل اجتماعيه
متخصصه لنقبه القراء والصحافيين العرب بما
يلتزم بتنميه حريه الصحافه العربيه
والتعزيز مفهوم الاستقلال الماليه للاعلام
الى الرياضه الان مع ديما محمد السايح
[موسيقى]
استراليا المفتوحه للتنس للمره العاشره في
تاريخه بفوزه على اليونانيه
دون مقابل
من الاسباني
اه بحضور ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد
بن سلمان جرت منافسات الجوله الثالثه من
بطوله العالم للفورميلا اي على حلبه
الدرعيه في العاصمه الرياض وعزف النشيد
الوطني السعودي قبيله انطلاق سباق كور
الدرعيه 2023 قبل ان يفوز الالماني باسكال
فرلاين بالسباق الثاني في الدرعيه بعد ما
فاز كذلك سباق الاول على الحلبه نفسها
الجمعه الماضيه
[موسيقى]
تتجه الانظار اليوم نحو ملعب الملك فهد
الدولي في الرياض حيث تقام مباراه الاتحاد
والفيحاء في نهائي كاس السوبر السعودي
الاتحاد يسعى لاحراز الكاس للمره الاولى
في تاريخه بعد ما سبق ان خسرها مرتين امام
الفتح في 2013 والهلال في 2018 عندما كانت
تقام من مباراه واحده بين بطلي الدوري
وكاس الملك قبل ان تتغير الى النظام
الحالي بمشاركه اربعه فرق الفيحاء بدوره
يبحث عن لقبه الاول في هذه البطوله
والثاني في تاريخه
المدرب البرتغالي نونو سانتو يرغب في
تحقيق اللقب الاول في مسيرته يقابله
الصربي فوق راسبتج الطامح لزياده غلته من
الالقاب مسابح
[موسيقى]
سجل لاعب الوسط البرازيلي كاسيمو كاسيميرو
هدفين ليقوده مانشستر يونايتد للفوز بي
ثلاثه اهداف مقابل هدف على ضيفه المنتمي
لدرجه الثانيه والتاهل للدور الخامس في
كاس الاتحاد الانجليزي
قبل ان يعزيزه مانشستر يونايتد بعد اربع
دقائق بتسديده منخفضه
تعادل باينو نخل المره الثالثه على
التوالي في الدوري الالماني بعد عوده ضيفه
بهدف ليضمن التعادل بهدف لمثله في الاسبوع
الثامن عشر من البطوله في الدقيقه الرابعه
وثلاثين ووضع الثاني في المقدمه وعادل
رنده الكولماني النتيجه للضيوف في الدقيقه
التاسعه والستون وبهذه النتيجه ارتفع رصيد
ضعيف الى 37 نقطه واستمر فشله في تحقيق
الفوز خلال العام الجديد بينما اصبح رصيد
اثنتين وثلاثين نقطه في المركز الخامس
اشعل موشرجي ويون البريين المدرجات في درب
المدينه اثر تعزيز الفريق لمركزه الثاني
في الدوري الالماني بفوزه على هرتبه برلين
بهدفين من دون مقابل الاول جاء في دقيقه
44 عبر النيل وسجل هدف التقدم الثاني
يونيون الفوز الرابع على التوالي في
البطوله في المقابل بقي هرتبلين في المركز
قبل الاخير بعد تكبده الهزيمه الثالثه على
التوالي منذ بدايه العام
في الارجنتين فاز ليفربول بليت على مضيفه
سنترال كورتوبا بهدفين دون رد في مباراته
الافتتاحيه بالدوري المحلي على ملعب
الفريدو تيرارا بمدينه
سانتياغولسترول الذي شهد احتفال الحارس
ارماني بكاس العالم ورفع نسخه طبق الاصل
للبطوله
ناتشوف تتحد تسجيل الضيوف في نهايه الشوط
الاول وضعف ريفل بليت النتيجه في الدقيقه
99 احتل على اثرها المركز الثاني بالترتيب
على باقي هذا الخبر نفسه ونعود الان الى
الزميل خالد
[موسيقى]
لسكان الاحياء المطوره بعد ازاله منازل
الاحياء العشوائيه في جده غربيه السعوديه
الخدمات الحكوميه المجانيه شملت الدفع
قيمه الايجارات لسكان التي تصل الى اكثر
من 516 مليون ريال فضلا عن توظيف 269
مواطن ومواطن وتسكني اكثر من 23,000 اسره
مع تسليم 5 وحدات سكنيه شملت الخدمات
الحكوميه المقدمه الى سكان ايضا تقدم
100,000 خدمه انها توزيعه خلال الغذائيه
وادويه وغيرها من الخدمه
نعيش خلال هذه الايام اول الاقترانات
الربيعيه السابعه والخامس تفاصيل في
التقويم مع خالد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اجمل النجوم الثريا واجمل ما بالكون القمر
واذا اجتمع الجمالين الجمال الكوني القمر
وجمال النجوم الثريا قال العرب القمر
جارنا الثريا فالمقارنه معناها الاجتماع
فاذا وقعت ثريا بجانب القمر في اليوم
السابع من الشهر الهجري قال العامه جراند
سابع مجيع وشابه فهو اماره وعلامه على
بدايه ظهور الربيع فبعض الحلال شبعان وبعض
الحلال جوعان وفي قادم الايام ستنتهي شده
البرد واللي يبيعك بالرخص وقت الشده بعوه
ببلاش
واقترحا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واهم الاقترانات سته اثنين شتوي واثنين
الربيع واثنين صيفي الشتوي انتهى قران
عادي برد مبادي و جراند تاسع برداسع ونحن
الان نعيش في اول الاقترانات الربيعيه
جراند سابع وجران خامس وهذا هو الزمان
وجربت اخوان الزمان فلم اجد صديقا جميلا
الغيبه في حال بعده وكم من صاحب عاشرته
فما دام لي يوما على حسني
عهديه
[موسيقى]
67000 متر مربع شهيده مكه تنشين المرحله
الاولى من مشروع حي حراثه
حكوميه منها وزاره الثقافه ولهي الملكيه
لمدينه مكه المكرمه
التاريخيه واستثمار عطاءات المكان
الطبيعيه وقيمته التراثيه وذلك بما ينسجم
ايضا مع مكانتي مكه المكرمه وبعدها
الدينيه والانسانيه والتاريخي
بعضها يعود تاريخه الى القرن الثاني من
الهجره يقدم مركز الملك فيصل للبحوث
والدراسات الاسلاميه اكثر من ثمانيه
وعشرين الفعل من المخطوطات الاصليه يحتفظ
المركز في مكتبته باكثر من 140,000 صوره
للمخطوطات المخزنه بطريقه حديث
ويشتهر او يشتهر ايضا بمجموعته الواسعه من
المخطوطات التي يعرضها من حين لاخر في
معرض متحف الفيصل
من معرض المخطوطات النادره في الرياض ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه
حياك الله يا هاني
اعطينا فكره عن اهم هذه المخطوطات النادره
المتواجده الان او المعروضه الان في
المتحف
اهلا بك مشاهدي قناه العربيه طبعا
المخطوطات الموجوده هنا في متحف الفيصل
وتحديدا في مركز الملك فيصل
للدراسات والبحوث والدراسات الاسلاميه في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض والذي كما ذكرت
ان يضم اكثر من
28,000 مخطوطه وهي من المخطوطات الاصليه
التي تم جمعها سواء من اقتناها من قبل
المركز او كذلك التي كانت لدى الملك فيصل
والتي كان يقتنيها اضافه الى ان ايضا هناك
اكثر من 140 مخطوطا وكذلك ايضا افلاما فقط
رقميه ما زالت موجوده وتحتفظ بها او يحتفظ
بها المركز عموما كل هذه الامور وكيفيه
ايضا على الحفاظ عليها وايضا كيفيه ايضا
عمليه استثمارها وايضا تعريف بها سوف تكون
معي همم الاستاذه رشا الفواز وهي مديره
الاصول والمتاحف هنا مركز مرحبا روشاوله
وتقدمين قليلا ونتكلم اليوم عن هذا هذا
المركز وعن هذا الارث النادر من المخطوطات
والذي تعود بعض المخطوطات الى القرن
الثاني الهجري كما ذكرت اهلا بك استاذ
هاني اهلا بكم متابعين العربيه نحن هنا في
مركز الملك فيصل نعنا ونرعى 28,000 مخطوط
اصلي من مجموعه مخطوطات المركز في متحف
الفيصل للمخطوط العربي اول متحف مختص
بالمخطوطات في العالم في هذا المتحف نقوم
بمعارض مؤقته مستمره بشكل دوري همم ومن
اهم المعارض الذي تشاهدنا اليوم هو معرض
اسفار الذي يحتوي سته اسباب هو الكتاب
الكبير فانت في جوله الكتاب همم
وممكن يعني نظهر اذا كنت همم ودينا نعرف
برده بعض المخطوطات وايضا لو ايضا يشاهدون
مشاهدي قناه العربيه وتتفضلين معي في هذه
الجهه هنا ونتعرف على هذا المخطوط لو
تنتقد بعض الكاميرا هذه الصوره لواحده من
المخطوطات النادي لو تعرفين عليها في هذا
السفر اللي هو سفر النساء ووقف العلم
نتكلم عن فضل النساء ووقفهم للعلم والعلوم
ودورهم في نشر المعارف والعلوم في العالم
هذا المخطوط هو مصحف مملوكي يعود القرن
السابع الهجري اوقفت الست مسكه مرضعه
سلطان احمد قالوون في مصر في مسجد بنت
ووقفت هذه المصحف للقراء يعتبر من اندر
المصاحف المملوكيه في العالم
وهم مقتنيات المركز كنا بعض المقتنيات
والمخطوطات النادره برده استاذه رشا وايضا
كنا نتحدث فيها عن اللي بن خلدون وكذلك
لبعض العلماء او ال- ال- المخطوطات
النادره لبعض العلماء الموجوده هنا في
المركز لو تحدد تتحدث عنها بشكل سريع وكيف
يتم الاهتمام بها في هذا في هذا المعرض
تحديدا همم
لكنوز مركز الملك فيصل للمخطوطات النادره
لدينا في المركز همم لعلها بخطوط بعضها
بخطوط مؤلفيها وهذا يعتبر سبب مثل مخطوطه
الحمد لله انت ذكرت لك وهو ديوان العبر
الخبر ديوان العبر ومبتدا او خبر هذا
المخطوطه بخط ابن خلدون بنفسه عليها خطها
المشرقي والمغربي همم وهذا محطوط نادر
يعتبر ايضا في مخطوط همم للفارس الشاعر
العربي اسامه بن ملقد بخط يده الوحيده في
العالم همم عدد من مخطوطات نادره جدا كيف
سالتني عن كيفيه العنايه بالمخطوطات همم
نحن هنا في المركز نعطينا بالمخطوطات من
حيث درجه الحراره ودرجه الرطوبه ودرجه
الاضاءه التي تكون موجوده في المكان ايضا
نحافظ عليها من خلال حفظها بنظام ارشفه
عالمي معتمد عالمي نظام ارشفه سحابي نقوم
بعمليات الترميم والتجليد والتوثيق الكامل
المخطوطات موجوده لدينا في المركز اذا كان
هذا الحديث
المتاحف والاصول هنا في المركز الامر
الغريب الذي تم يعني همم لاول مره اعرف عن
هذه المعلومه ان هذه المخطوطه تحفظ في
مكان ودرجه حراره معينه مثلا درجه حراره
و20 درجه مئويه ونسبه الرطوبه ايضا كما
ذكرت بين 55 الى 60% من نسبه الرطوبه وهو
في هذا المكان فعلا اول ما دخلنا انا شعرت
بروده شديده ودرجه حراره منخفضه فكانت هذه
من المعلومات
الاوليه او اول مره اعرف عنها وكانت تحفظ
فيها هذه المخطوطات شكرا لك من معرض
المخطوطات النادره في الرياض
على مساحه تفوقه 67.000 متر مربع تشهد مكه
تشرين المرحله الاولى من مشروع حي حراري
الثقافيه وباشراف عده جهات حكوميه منها
وزاره الثقافه ولا هي الملكيه لمدينه مكه
المكرمه
نتابع همم ربما للمزيد حول هذا الحي مع
مراسل العربيه سلطان السلامي الذي ينضم
الينا الان من حراقات
حياك الله اولا الان متى سيتم تشيل هذا
الحقيقه وهذا المتحف وما ابرز ما يشتمل
عليه
اهلا بك خالد اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل دشنت اليوم المرحله الاولى
تبقى المرحله الثانيه سوف تدشن خلال السته
اشهر القادمه تم الانتهاء من مساحه 40,000
متر من 120,000 متر هي المساحه الاجماليه
لهذا الحي وهو حي حراء الثقافي اريد
ناخذكم في جوله داخل المتحف تحديدا هذا
الحي الذي يتشكل من معرض الوحي ومتحف
القران الكريم نتحدث على حكايه نزول الوحي
هنا في مكه المكرمه وتحديدا في جبل
النور نتحدث على شاشات عرض تحكي تفاصيل
قصه نزول الوحي نتحدث على متحف ضخم يضم
مجسمات لجبل النور هنا وكذلك مجسمات اخرى
للغار لنقل الثوار والمشاهدين
والمعتمرين والزوار وكذلك المقيمين في مكه
الى رحله ابداعيه اثرائيه تقدم بشكل نوعي
وعصري وتحكى بثمانيه لغات كل المعلومات
والمجسمات الموجوده هنا اعتمدت وفق
المصادر الصحيحه والدقيقه لهذا الجبل اريد
ان اخذ تفاصيل اكثر ااا من خلال هذا
المعرض ينضم اليه الان الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه الاستثماريه المطوره هنا في حي حراء
الثقافي بدايه ما هو المميز هنا في هذا
المعرض بحكم قربه من جبل النور اهلا وسهلا
بكم المعرض طبعا يتكلم عن قصه نزول الوحي
عن النبي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم بحكم
انه هذا المشروع يستثم عطاءات المكان
التاريخيه والثقافيه فراينا نحن نعرف
الزوار لجورون هذا المكان من انحاء العالم
بقصه نزول الوحي في هذا المكان
المشروع يتكون مجموعه مكونات كلها مرتبطه
بالسياقه التاريخي المرتبط بالمشروع بقصه
الوحي كذلك عندنا المكون الثاني متحف
القران الكريم اللي كلهم ترتبط بقصه نزول
الوحيين ايضا خالد اريد ناخذكم في جوله
سريعه همم في
الجهه الاخرى من من المعرض هنالك تفاصيل
اخرى تم تجسيد غار حراء بشكل واقعي وبكافه
التفاصيل المتعلقه بهذا الغال ليستطيع
الزائر والمؤتمر والحاج الوصول الى هذا
المجسم والجلوس داخل غار لي معايشه الواقع
ايضا الوصول الى اعلى الجبل تم عمل
المسارات مشيه خاصه في وقت سابق يقطع
الحاجه والمعتمره والزائر مسافه ساعه
كامله للوصول الى قمه الجبل الذي يقع على
ارتفاع 600 متر نتحدث اليوم بعد هذه
المسارات يستطيع الوصول الى هذا القمه او
هذه القمه في المساحه لا تتجاوز او مده
تجاوز النصف ساعه كذلك تم تخسيس مسار
للسيارات لوصول بشكل اسرع للحافلات السياح
وغيره اخيرا بس اعرف ان الوقت ضيق واريد
لكم المجسم الذي تم عملوا من قبل هذا
المعرض لتجسيد الصوره الحقيقيه للغار كيف
هو شكله في الاعلى حتى من لا يستطيع
الوصول اليه هذا الشكل بكامل التفاصيل
وبكامل ابعاده
وتفاصيله وهذا يقع الغار في اعلى القمه
يكون شكل واضح وحي للزوار
اسرائيل
حوادث القتل في الولايات المتحده تتصاعد
1400 ضحيه خلال العام الجاري 2023
السعوديه تسجل انخفاضا في وفيات واصابات
الحوادث المروريه وجدال حول ارتفاع اسعار
تام
الرابعه تتجول في حي حراء الثقافي توثيق
لتاريخ مكه الدين والانسان والمكانه
التاريخيه
وترقب لنهائي السوبر السعودي الاتحاد
والفيحاء وصراع اللقب الاول
[موسيقى]